so my name is my scale we're talking
about mathematical function properties
so that talk is about functionality
that's planned for version 12 point to
the SIS in 1201 will not been in
Indonesia released so we have other
three types of mathematical function
function properties so set to article
properties so we'll have functions like
function the main function range
actually those functions are already in
Mathematica we have extended them so now
they work for for a larger number of
functions and new functions are
injective function c surjective function
c and by active function c so what's the
C that's something new so we had we had
some functions that ended with you and
and returned to or false but in in this
case we C stands for condition so we we
may return condition for the function to
to be injective or or surjective and in
case we we may also not be able to
decide what their function is injective
or surjective so if it's false it means
that if actually really is not injective
for instance if we cannot tell which of
course always will happen for some
functions then we just return none
evaluated so that's that's how it's
that's why we change the design from Q
at the end to see at the end that you at
the end will always return true or false
so and then there is a series of
topological and analytic properties so
function discontinuous function
singularities will give description of
the singularity and discontinuity set
and then we have another 3c functions
continuous function C holomorphic
function C and meromorphic function C
and finally the sign properties of real
functions or that's how I called the
group so its functions
i Function monotonicity and function
convexity so in the sense they are sign
properties since at least for some
function monotonicity z' is the sign of
derivative and convexity is sign of the
second derivative so this sense they are
they're also order related properties
that's where the sign comes in so the
first new function injective function c
so a function that goes from x to y is
injective if for any Y in Y the equation
f of x equals y has at most one solution
X in X and equivalently the function is
injective if for any two different
points the values are different so for
instance we can evaluate injective
function c for for exponential and it's
an injective function plot the
exponential see that there is at most
one solution for for every so each each
horizontal line intersects the
graphically at most one point then we
check whether podriatic function is
injective it's not and we can see that
there are some horizontal lines the
intersect the graph in more than one
point
now the injectivity depends on the
specification of x and y so we usually
say that the function is injective but
what we actually mean the function we
actually have to say what what x and y
are to know so here we specify the this
set axes complexity now now exponential
is not injective anymore
so by default if we don't specify the
domain is reals
and if we say quadratic function but now
we restrict the set X to positive values
of x then quadratic function is
injective because we are looking just
that this part the right hand side part
of the parabola and we can also restrict
the the codomain the set Y so we are
looking at injectivity of the function X
cubed minus X but only for for the set
on which the values are greater than 1/2
so we change the set Y here and if we
look Val use R greater than 1/2 so it's
above this line and then the function is
injective over the whole reals it's not
well for for for univariate function
here so it doesn't have to be very don't
have to be real if it's complex them
yeah forever actually yeah for the main
method for for the deciding injectivity
of univariate real functions will be
just called monotonic but but yes so
[Music]
well the most general and the slowest
method would be to it's a quantifier
it's a quantified statement the
definition of of injectivity we can
eliminate the quantifier if if we can
then we got the solution then then of
course we have certain properties of
certain function we have we have
collected properties of functions so we
know which which specific names function
is for instance increasing on some
interval some such and then we can use
you can we can combine those properties
with you know we know how it combines
for composition for its the composition
of injective functions will be injective
and so this kind of stuff so that's this
does the fast
I thought if if we can get all the
information and here's injectivity with
symbolic parameters and we can see the
nice new conditional expression
formatting so this function is is
injective if the condition is is
satisfied because we eats we only know
that it's true if the condition is
satisfied we don't know that it's not
satisfied it's not a necessary it's it's
not a necessary not a necessary
condition it is a necessary way it's a
sufficient condition not a necessary
condition and we have a mapping so it's
a mapping from r2 to r2 and and we prove
that is injective this one of course is
it's very easy to decide so you can
solve for X and solve for y and this
here is a full syntax so the injective
projective and bioactive function will
have the same syntax so it's the
functions
so it's either one functional or
register functions then conditions on X
conditions on Y X variables Y variables
so the variables in the domain variables
in the co-domain
and then there is the domain ascends
reals or complexes that are just two
values for for done whether it's a real
function or complex function and the
actual mapping that that needs to be
injective is is the functions that are
restricted to to this set so as is the
solution set of conditions for X T is
the solution set of conditions for Y and
we take intersection of s with universe
image of T and nothing goes into T
so the solutions of y-coordinates and
that's where the mapping is supposed to
be injective or subjective our project
uses the same syntax so now let's look
the bijective subjective so the function
is subjective if for any Y in Y the
equation f of X equals y has at least
one solution so exponential function is
not surjective because the non positive
values are not attained and tangent is
subjective because all values are
attained subjectivity again depends on
the specification of such xmii so if we
specify that we want exponential but
only on the set of positive axis and
into the set of y greater than one so we
are looking for the mapping from this
positive x into y greater than 1 then
the function is subjective and on the
other hand if we look at tangent over
the complexes then it's not a surjective
function because we can check it with
function range
iron - I are not in the range of
function tangent
so now if we restrict ourselves to the
set without this iron - I don't I'm
gently subjective and here's the full
syntax it's the same as for injective
function and now projective function
sees of the function is by jekt if if
the equation of X f of X equals y has
exactly one solution so it's brought
both injective and surjective so here is
a function that's by jacket if over the
reals we can plot it to see it in this
it is it's a monotonic function this is
a univariate real function so reject if
is the same as knowing that that covers
all values and tangent is not projective
because it's not injective but now if we
look at the first function over the
complexes again if we specify x and y
differently first function is not by
objective over the complexes on the
other hand because it's not injective
and tangent is a bijective function if
we restricted to a single period
or the algorithms for this so again the
the fallback algorithm is right
everything has quantified formula and
telling me the quantifiers basically the
then more the easier algorithm we have
again we have certain database of
functions and values that they that they
attain so we can analyze it and and then
you use some rules of how it carries
through function composition to decide
hopefully again this is the first method
if if we can do that otherwise we have
to do some computation which which will
release then there are some criteria for
say complex function is complex function
that has essential singularity so we can
use Picard erm so that you have every
neighborhood of the singularities it
attains each value except at most one
infinitely many times so we know that
the function for instance not injective
so that's this one of the those criteria
like that we have a bunch of things like
this also built in
okay so now slightly different family
function so function hopefully hopefully
well it's one thing is that the
implementation is not quite quite quite
finished yet but so this part is
actually not not written yet
the the polynomial but but hopefully we
for instance we may we put some stuff
into the cylindrical decomposition
algorithm so it ends earlier if it
decides that the function is for
instance not injective finds in one
fiber five finds two points then we are
done we don't have to compute the rest
of quantifier elimination so it might be
faster than so you can you can put
element integers in in the condition and
in some case it will work it's harder
than
so function discontinuities it will give
a condition such that the function is
continuous outside the solution set of
the condition so in particular the
condition will also contain it will be
also true for all the points where the
function is not defined so this
continued it is of floor here is an
encoding of integers as an equation
discontinuities of tangent log X so so
that here over the complexes so we have
this will be the branch cut off log this
was this is the point where tangent is
not defined and X equal zero came out
the branch point for log o we we try to
treat and everything as equation an
inequality rather than the domain
condition it could say X integers but
yeah just just to be sort of consistent
between all this so it's always
equations inequalities
you know possibly oh the so the
counter-argument he would be if you have
composed function then you you would get
the sine of pi whatever the inner
function of this was like floor of log
here you get this inside the sine and
then you would get condition that
there's some complicated expression is
an element of integers which sort of
none of our function would handle anyway
so it's a dead and here that we have
some hope that that say reduce will do
something with it argue that reduce
could handle the integers to get the
absolute to to get the salt version of
the condition so this is this is a very
fast function because it just collects
all the information from knowledge of
discontinuities of all the built-in
function so as you can see here it's
just collected the knowledge of
discontinuities of logarithm and and of
tangent so this function takes no time
now if you want to solve it of course it
will take try to take a bit of time so
this is this is just just a structural
function
yeah which was wrong X equals
a parametric solution but again that's
that are you yeah here so that instead
of integers have parameterize thing yeah
yes okay what's wrong with it okay so so
that's that's that's what I just
explained so if you if you want if you
get it solved then the first thing is
that that it's not that useful for for
applying somewhere else as a condition
because it will have additional
parameters and second you add huge huge
time to the computation if you know you
can you can always get the condition and
if you want itself then you can apply
reduce to it or solve to it or something
then of course it it will take many
orders of magnitude usually timewise
more to solve it and then to generate
the condition
[Music]
so basically so that's the next thing so
the solution set is of so this continues
its not MIMO so the function is going to
be continuous outside the set doesn't
mean everything in the set is a
discontinuity so we just collect all the
discontinuities of all the of all the
functions involved the resulting
function may may not have
discontinuities so for instance yeah so
that was next example so if we plot this
function so we produce this continues if
you need step and gamma but what
actually function is continuously
it so happens because they they cancel
right or it gives a set that contains
all the discontinuities but it might
contain more that yes so in this case it
yeah it just contains the solutions yes
not like yes and I'm running out of time
so right so that that's a much harder
much harder situationally you can take
the function discontinuous and now
you'll have to check that hopefully hope
that that it's a finite number of them
and and then check for each of them
limits or something to say that it's
actual discontinuity right right so so
this this is more useful for for
determining the function is definitely
continuous outside of the cert so
function singularities now I'm really
running late so the function see whether
Rarity's this is a function similar but
but if function is analytic outside the
solution set of the condition again with
the same the same caveats that we may
get to large that it's a collection of
all singularities of all functions
involved so continuous function C this
will test whether a specified function
is continuous
so here's this function and so it's one
point to make is that it's a continuous
and defined everywhere and it's not
continuous as that it can be extended
but the actual expression we give is
continuous so it's sine of X by axis not
continuous at 0 because doesn't we don't
define what it is as a zero if we just
say sine of X by X if we say that it's a
piecewise function that outside zero is
sine of X by X at zero is 1 then it's a
continuous function and if we put either
we'll get a condition saying that the
function is not continuous unless is 1
and here is a multivariate continuous
function with condition restricting the
domain in which is supposed to be
conditions continuous so the syntax is
functions constrains variables and
domain which is real or complexes and we
have similarity to functions which I
will just mention column or tick
function C which tests whether the
function is holomorphic or real analytic
and we have meromorphic function C which
that's whether a function is meromorphic
or locally a ratio of real analytic
function I don't think anybody talks
about real function being meromorphic so
but it also works over there is and it
means that it's a locally right ratio of
analytic functions a function sine is
the sine of a function like that either
function doesn't have a fixed sign it's
as indeterminate and though it has an
option strictness so X square is not
strictly positive so it will give
indeterminate and
we make it a condition for function sign
and pieces larger condition so we need
to unpack it to to see what he was and
similar function we have cout function
monotonicity this one is only for
univariate function so it's slightly
different syntax that than the function
sine so function sine can can work for
multivariate functionality in cities for
univariate again can be strictmode
maternity week maternity and convexity
convexity can be a multivariate function
too can be convex so for instance here
is a convexity of a multivariate
function that's what the function looks
like
okay so now we have the comment about
matters that I already made so so there
are three three types of methods so very
very sick collected information about
properties of mathematical functions
then we use closure properties to try to
derive the properties based on this
collected information and then there are
fall backs fall back
computational criteria that actually
require solving equations and
inequalities and quantifier elimination
that are much slower than the first two
methods so this is all that I have thank
you
[Applause]